so it says a company is selling 15
widgets so which is just some type of
object right five of which are defective
okay meaning they're bad they're not
good and it says what is the probability
that if you purchase four of these
widgets that a all four are good be
exactly two are good or see at least two
are good okay let's take this one part
at a time so what's the problem that all
four are good okay well the first thing
you want to do is you want to figure out
how many are good well we know that
there's 15 widgets 10 are good five will
just say our bad okay so we got 15
totals 10 good five bad but we want all
four to be good so how many ways can you
get four good widgets out of the ten
that there are that are good so that's
going to be 10 combination four so out
of ten objects how many ways are there
to choose for the order doesn't matter
okay so that's why we're using
combinations and not permutations but
another way to look at this also in some
times this is helpful for students this
might be helpful for you too is to look
at we want out of the five bad ones
we're gonna be choosing none okay and
what you'll notice here is that the 10
and the 5 that's our 15 total widgets
the 4 plus the zero is the four that
were that we're choosing okay but
remember when you do probability what
you're doing is you're calculating you
know the number of successes what you
want out of the total possible outcomes
and the total ways to pick four objects
out of 15 where the order is not
important it doesn't matter is going to
be 15 combination for 15 see for however
you want to say that so I did this prior
to this video here calculated this for
us and it comes out to if you reduce it
all down to 213 okay so you can check
your answer there okay let's go to Part
B now it says exactly two are good so
that means if two are good that means
that two are going to be bad right
because there's four total so what we're
going to do is we do the same type of
setup we're going to say out of the ten
good ones we want to choose two and out
of the five bad ones we want to choose
two and it's all divided by the total
ways of choosing for widgets out of the
15 okay and again I calculated this here
for us before this video and this comes
out to
30 over 91 so you can check your answer
with that Part B okay and then the last
one Part C we have at least two are good
so that means at least that means two
are good three are get good or four good
okay so let's go ahead and calculate
that so we've got out of the ten we want
to or good so that's 10 choose two and
then fight you are going to be bad all
the five bad ones over 15 choose 4
that's the total ways of choosing 4 out
of 15 plus 10 choose 3 times 5 choose 1
over 15 choose 4 plus 10 choose 4 times
5 choose 0 over 15 choose 4